[Musique]
il a commencé comme youtubeur il a
d'ailleurs fait profiter Jean-Luc
Mélenchon de ses talents sur le Web
avant de se lancer lui-même en politique
et d'être élu député sous les couleurs
de la France
[Musique]
insoumise bonjour Antoine léomand
bonjour alors en quelques années
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est de la
personnalité politique la plus suivie
sur youtube il a 2600000 abonnés sur
Twitter 2100000 sur TikTok est-ce qu'on
peut dire que c'est au moins en partie
grâce à vous oui en partie parce que
c'était mon rôle c'est vrai de de
construire une équipe et depuis
maintenant de nombreuses années et je
pense que ce que j'ai su faire c'est
trouver les gens qui savaient faire
parce que moi je maîtrisais une partie
des choses mais voilà et surtout bah
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est quelqu'un qui a
de la PT pour ça il aime beaucoup
trouver des manières de faire passer son
discours politique et je pense que la
force de son de ses réseaux sociaux ça
tient au fait que il essaie de faire
passer un message politique un message
programmatique et il essaie pas de faire
de la com alors il y a un peu de la com
des
fois il essaie de faire il essaie de
faire passer un message politique et je
pense que ça dit aussi beaucoup des
raisons pour lesquelles l'attachement à
Jean-Luc Mélanchon en tant que personne
est d'abord un attachement à des idées à
un programme parce que c'est par les
réseaux sociaux qu'il a réussi à faire
passer ça al on va parler plus en
longueur dans un de votre rôle au côté
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais d'abord
j'aimerais
qu'on qu'on écoute la façon dont il
parle lui-même de TikTok et vous allez
me dire vous-même ce que vous en
pensez je me
téléporte le 10 avril on vote c'est
l'élection présidentielle on vote TikTok
c'est un mode d'expression faut le
prendre comme pour ce que c'est si
c'était de la peinture bah c'est de la
peinture si c'est de la musique c'est de
la musique c'est TikTok c'est du TikTok
donc vous allez pas faire du you YouTube
à TikTok voilà alors c'est un art faut
apprendre bon alors est-ce qu'il a bien
compris ce que c'est que le TikTok comme
il dit il a totalement compris moi ce
que je dis toujours c'est qu'il y a une
grammaire sur les réseaux sociaux chaque
réseau social a sa grammaire c'est comme
une langue et d'une certaine manière moi
par exemple je suis très bon pour faire
une recette de risotto je peux vous
l'expliquer en français c'est super bien
par contre si vous commencez à me
demander de l'expliquer en russe ou en
chinois je vais pas y arriver donc il
faut d'abord que j'apprenne la langue et
ensuite je pourrais vous parler de ma
recette de risotto les réseaux sociaux
c'est pareil faut d'abord apprendre les
codes la langue de ces réseaux sociaux
et ensuite bah c'est réussir à faire
rentrer le discours politique à
l'intérieur de cette langue là et c'est
c'est je pense toute la force de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est d'avoir réussi
à s'imprégner de comment fonctionne
chacun de ses réseaux sociaux et de les
faire fonctionner comme ça c'est le
premier homeom politique que j'ai vu par
exemple sur Youtube inviter ses abonnés
à appuyer sur le pouce lev ou faire ce
genre de choses c'est ça les codes des
réseaux sociaux c'est ouis mais venant
de lui connu pour être plutôt un tribin
érudi diplômé de philosophie et de l
moderne ça peut surprendre end quand
même ça été compliqué de le convaincre
d'aller vers ça pas du tout parce que
c'était quelque chose Jean-Luc c'est
quelqu'un qui a toujours cherché à être
indépendant dans ses modes d'expression
il a fait un blog en 2008 quand c'était
le l'époque des blogs il existe toujours
son blog et puis ensuite étape après il
avait fait le miniel aussi quand c'était
l'époque du Minitel Jean-Luc il aime
bien dire nous quand j'ai moi quand j'ai
commencé à militer on tournait les
tractes à la ronéo et maintenant je peux
faire des tractes à 2 millions de vues
d'une certaine manière avec les TikTok
et il va jusqu'à parodier wden par
exemple tout à fait tu Macron hors de ma
vue a vu ouais ben ça ça fait partie de
ces codes là réussir à capter des choses
qui se passent sur les réseaux sociaux
parce qu'il y a un monde par sur cette
vidéo elle elle a fait elle a fait
beaucoup de fait un carton puis c'était
la première c'était le lancement du
compte TikTok et on avait je pense
réussi à à capter quelque chose en plus
il y avait une blague sur il était à
République c'était une blague sur la
République c'est moi un peu
d'autodérision sur sur le moment des
perquisitions et tout ça avait bien
fonctionné et ensuite on a réussi à
faire fonctionner très fort ces réseaux
sociaux moi je pense que dans une large
mesure le score qu'on réalise chez les
jeunes notamment qui s'informment
beaucoup avec les réseau soci sociaux il
vient de là mais il vient aussi du fait
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça l'intéresse
c'est pas quelqu'un qui va prendre une
boîte de com et je sais pas quoi il aime
ça derrière ces vidéos parfois rigolotte
il y a aussi une vraie stratégie alors
vous disaz ouais on fait pas de la come
sur les réseaux sociaux et en même temps
en 2017 vous expliquiez on est en train
de faire un pied Denez gigantesque au
système médiatique et franchement c'est
jouissif plus vous parlez de la chaîne
Youtube plus on s'autonomise de vous
alors le vous j'imagine he que ce sont
les journalistes c'est vrai que c'est en
kikinant les journalistes hein ça vient
poser des questions ça empêche les
hommes politiques de dérouler leur
discours sous forme presque de
propagande alors que sur Youtube on fait
ce qu'on veut ah bah sur Youtube on peut
raconter ce qu'on veut mais donc c'est
de la com le non justement parce que le
système médiatique il a des défauts qui
sont notamment le fait qu'on impose des
thèmes et qu'on impose un temps et les
réseaux sociaux ce qui permettent de
faire c'est de s'extraire de ça par
exemple parler de la 6e République dans
une matinale France interre de 8 minutes
dans laquelle il y a par ailleurs une
question sur l'immigration sur
l'insécurité sur je sais pas quoi c'est
compliqué mais par contre si vous faites
une vidéo de youtube vous pouvez faire
faire 30 minutes sur la 6e république
comment ça se passe et ça permet
d'expliquer c'est ça qu'on recherche
nous on va parler un peu de votre
parcours politique si vous voulez bien
parce que j'ai découvert qu'avant d'être
mélanchonist vous avez été baayrouiste
sur la campagne présidentielle de 2007
vous aviez presque 18 ans qu'est-ce qui
vous a attiré chez François Baayou bon
il y avait plusieurs choses déjà il
proposait c'était un peu Macron avant
l'heure en réalité il proposait la
droite la gauche tout ça c'est un peu
vieux ça ça ça sert à rien et cetera et
puis moi je veux faire travailler
ensemble les gens qui ont envie de faire
des bonnes choses et puis il a il
parlait d'une 6e République alors
c'était une 6e république présidentielle
et maintenant moi je me suis mis à
distance de ça il y avit un certain
nombre de choses et y compris sur les
médias il y avait eu une intervention de
François berou assez marquante dans
laquelle il avait dit à Claire Chazal
mais vous de toute façon votre média
c'est bug et bug c'est l'ami de Nicolas
Sarkozi donc comment voulez-vous être
vous avez vu en françois bairou le
candidat antisystème c'était c'est mais
en fait de fait c'était un peu le
candidat qui sortait des CADES
traditionnels à ce momentl mais avec une
sensibilité au en même temps et droite
et gauche euh ben moi ma mère ma mère
était était de droite parce que
maintenant elle vote pour Jean-Luc
mchant mais elle était de droite
Gauliste et mon père plutôt de gauche et
donc la moyenne en en 2007 c'était
François berou et qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé alors pour basculer il s'est passé
plusieurs choses il y a d'abord eu la
réforme des retraites de bon déjà le
MoDem a pas fait grand-chose après 2007
ça a été un peu un peu mou euh la le la
réforme des retraites de Nicolas Sarkozi
en 2010 ça m'a convaincu qu'il y avait
un problème la crise des subprime
également parce que les banques ont fait
n'importe quoi on sauve les banques se
mettent à spéculer contre la dette des
états il y a quand même un petit
problème démocratique parce qu'ensuite
la conséquence c'est qu'on fait la
réforme des retraite pour sauver la det
et cetera et puis j'ai découvert le
livre de Jean-Luc Mélenchon en 2010 qui
s'appelle kits enous et je me suis dit
ben non non c'est incroyable je suis en
accord avec 95 % de ce qu'il raconte
donc je me suis intéressé à ce qu'il
disait puis en fait je me suis rendu
compte que sur les 5 % où j'étais pas
d'accord c'était moi qui avait tort et
c'était lui qui avait raison et donc là
vous vous êtes engagé pour lui je me
suis engagé ouais moi mais sous pseudo
au début vous avez pas voulu assumer
publiquement cet engagement vous
expliquz c'est vrai qu'au début c'est
pas évident d'assumer publiquement un
positionnement politique vous vous dites
que ça va peut-être constituer un frein
pour l'avenir professionnel vous étiez
pas encore un insoumis dans l'âme c'est
pas ça c'est que là on est en en 2017 au
moment où on fait ça et moi j'ai jamais
voulu faire de la politique à un métier
c'était pas mon moi je suis sociologue
de formation je voulais être chercheur
en sociologie c'est ça mon c'était ça
mon dada et d'une certaine manière bah
quand vous sortez du du champ de la
recherche pour pouvoir y revenir faut
pas nécessairement avoir faire montrer
un engagement politique
surtout marqué au fer rouge quoi c'est
ça après bon bah au bout d'un moment
c'est difficile aussi parce que que il y
a besoin de porter la parole de ce qu'on
fait justement sur les réseaux sociaux
les médias vous savez comment c'est ils
sont demandeurs de de personnag comme ça
et moi j'ai incarné en quelque sorte la
communication numérique de Jean-Luc
mchan donc au bout d'un moment bah voilà
et c'est un Antoine léomand très
différent de celui sous pseudo qu'on a
découvert à l'Assemblée en 2022 pour sa
toute première prise de parole on va en
revoir un un extrait j'étais tremblotant
pour ma première intervention dans cette
assemblée qu'il me soit permis avant de
prendre la parole sur le fond de dire un
mot je siège tout en haut de l'hémicycle
et en cet instant je veux rendre hommage
à à ceux qui nous ont précédé dans ce
qui s'appelait jadis la montagne et qui
portait depuis ces hauteurs l'idéal
républicain que nous défendons encore
aujourd'hui suivant les mots de Jean
ferra je veux dire depuis ce lieu qu'il
y a ici avec nous la France qui répond
toujours du nom de Robespierre alors cet
hommage à Robespierre au début bah
certains ont cru que c'était une blague
ou une provocation mais en fait non
c'est très sérieux c'est très sérieux
parce que Maximilien Robespierre c'est
un des personnage centux de la
Révolution française quelqu'un qui porte
dès le début l'idée d'une république
profondément démoc prtique est
profondément sociale Robespierre dit nul
ne peut entasser des monceaux de blé à
côté de son semblable qui meurt de faim
et si on c'est votre modèle politique on
a l'impression c'est pas c'est pas
nécessairement tous les ans vous allez
commémorer sa mort à haras et justement
choisis Robespierre parce que il est
très caricaturé c'est un personnage qui
est présenté comme l'instigateur de la
terreur un dictateur et cetera et en
réalité ce qui correspond à une réalité
non parce que toute cette histoire là
elle est créée par les ennemis de
robespier qui justement l'envoie à
l'échafaud c'est une histoire qui est
créée la erreur par exemple donc le
consensus des
historiens il y a quelques historiens
qui peuent regardez par exemple
Jean-Clément Martin c'est moi le un des
ouvrages qui m'a le plus marqué c'est
celui de Jean-Clément Martin parce que
il explique bien comment la terreur le
robespier dictateur et cetera et cetera
c'est quelque chose qui est créé après
sa mort en réalité pas la loi des
suspects ah mais la loi des suspects je
suis pas nécessairement d'accord avec ça
je je dis pas que robespier c'est
parfait par ailleurs sur le sur le le
droit de vote des femmes bon il s'est
jamais exprimé sur le sujet mais en même
temps Robespierre c'est celui qui
défendait le début l'abolition de l'ESCL
c'est celui qui défend le droit de vote
des Juifs c'est celui qui vient porter
des questions à l'intérieur de la
révolution qui sont d'une modernité
absolue vous vous définissez comme un
révolutionnaire vous oui complètement
oui une révolution citoyenne par les
urnes mais un changement de constitution
c'est une révolution par les urnes parce
que en fait y a une phrase de pendant la
réforme des retraites que vous avez
lancé dans l'hémicycle qui m'a un peu
marqué vous avez dit ah bah Macron est
la mauvaise République vous vouliez en
avoir fini le 14 juillet vous aurez une
prise de la Bastille un petit côté les
aristocrates à la lanterne là-dedans
quand même non moi ça m'a aussi un peu
fait penser à cette fameuse photo de
Thomas porte le pied sur un ballon de
foot avec le visage d'Olivier du sob
dessus ça donne l' envie de vous poser
la question jusqu'où est-ce que vous
êtes prêt à aller pour vos idées
jusqu'aux urnes mais justement quand
quand non mais le la référence que je
fais je fais une référence à un discours
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur lequel il
était critiqué parce qu'il a dit ah bah
la mauvaise République et tout le monde
lui tombe dessus ah oui la mauvaise
République il est pas républicain et
cetera et moi quand il y a des
polémiques comme ça j'aime bien rentrer
dedans je c'est pour moi c'est un
plaisir le la la la bataille politique
convaincre les gens sur des idé ou enfin
les mots ils peuvent être perçus par les
gens différemment ce que vous avez dit
ça peut être perçu comme un appellement
un soulèvement par les armes ben c'est
c'est qu'on m'aura mal compris parce que
jamais j'appelle à la violence et
justement quand je dis vous aurez votre
prise de la Bastille je parle de faire
une manifestation place de la
Bastille et je trouve que mais non mais
parce que c'est c'est c'est quand même
j'aime bien les mots j'aime bien j'ai
j'ai une formation de littéraire en plus
de sociologue et moi j'aime bien choisir
les mots et venir sur cette idée de
tiens la Bastille faire une
manifestation a ation et cetera le 14
juillet pour moi le 14 juillet c'est une
date qui est centrale dans notre
histoire et justement je célèbre tous
les 14 juillet je fais des fêtes de la
révolution dans ma circonscription tout
le monde me au début pensait que j'étais
complètementembré avec mes histoires et
en fait je viens raconter une histoire
nationale qui est une histoire
révolutionnaire parce que c'est ça
l'histoire de notre pays le la cocarte
que vous me voyez porter là c'est le
symbole de notre drapeau il vient de la
Révolution notre drapeau est un drapeau
révolutionnaire la Marseillaise est un
champ révolutionnaire la devise Liberté
Égalité Fraternité c'est Robespierre qui
l'a inventé donc vous voyez l'histoire
de notre pays moderne tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui il vient de la Révolution et
j'essaie de porter ce message là on va
terminer l'émission par notre quiz qui
désormais traditionnel je vous explique
le principe il faut que vous complétiez
les phrases que je vais vous proposer on
y va avec mon physique d'enfant de cœur
les gens pensent que que je suis droite
ça vous arrive ouais ça m'arrive non
mais il y avait beaucoup de gens qui
pensait qui pensait ça au début ou qui
quand même il vient de beou et cetera il
est un peu chelou mais en réalité non
mon engagement est profondément à gauche
et on peut pas être révolutionnaire et
de droite ou alors c'est une révolution
nationale qui n'est vraiment pas mat
tasse de thé Jean-Luc et moi c'est c'est
une histoire d'abord de camaraderie et
désormais je pense une amitié solide et
sincère et euh pour moi ça reste l'homme
politique marquant du début de ce de ce
21e siècle sans doute celui qui a permis
que la gauche en France ne soit pas
réduite en poussière comme elle l'a été
dans autre pays enfin quand je vois que
Louis Boyard fait plus de vues que moi
sur TikTok je le félicite parce que je
l'adore ouais vraiment jalousie ah non
non jamais Louis bah vous voyez voilà
vous avez trouvé la photo non Louis
c'est un un ami pareil je le connaissais
pas lui avant de de devenir député et
désormais on est on s'entend comme Laron
enfire avec Louis donc vraiment c'est un
un excellent ami et quelqu'un qui je
trouve fait un travail magnifique
justement sur les réseaux sociaux pour
convaincre la jeunesse et vraiment Louis
si tu nous écoutes et ben félicitations
merci Antoine léomand d'être venu dans
la politique et moi merci à vous pour
[Musique]
l'invitation